[Music]
this week the new 50-pound note came
into circulation but how long will we'll
be using it Britain is shifting to a
cashless society one of the fastest
rates in the world according to a recent
Bank of England report it says the
Britain is only a few years behind the
most cashless countries like Sweden
Finland and the Netherlands in 2017
debit card transactions actually
overtook cash payments in Britain and
more than 5 million people hardly used
cash at all but I repute even some
Street baskets and beggars now want you
to pay by a card the result is that the
banks are closing down branches and
getting rid of cash machines because
they say fewer people are using them now
this suits the banks because both are
expensive to maintain but is it really
what we want as someone who doesn't feel
comfortable with that award of cash on
my person am I just an aging ladder as
campaigners argue are we all being
nudged in the direction of the cashless
society
by the financial institutions not
because it suits us but because it suits
them
they go in and they go to the taxi I
don't know really whether we can I knew
I had to consult a financial guru so
that I was up to speed for Greg's debate
Mark Carney
I tried Mark Carney I tried Christine
Lagarde neither were available so
instead I went through my box set of the
pledge from you I am of the opinion that
crypto is the future we will almost
certainly see a correction of its purely
upward trend and likely some regulation
to boot but in my view crypto and in
particularly Bitcoin is - money today
what the internet was - communication in
the late 90s I see it as the future now
that's that's one very smart girl but
that's one Michele gob in December 2017
just for your information Bitcoin has
now lost more than a quarter of its
value at the last week its current price
of around $9,500 as a way of its
all-time high 20 say on that she said
you will almost see almost certainly see
a correction or correction
bitcoin is a very volatile asset I don't
dispute that not least because I think
he's confusing the issue I think this is
a fascinating topic Greg Dyke one of the
most interesting on this program today
if I may be so bold because I'm a big
fan of technology I don't use cash for
me I found it's such an inconvenience
the tip that I'd give my hairdresser
when she's done my highlights is have
you seen what you've done to me I won't
be coming back I like by the way I would
say can I add the tip onto my card more
often than not they say yes with a lot
of this sort of cashless society and the
fact that was heading in that direction
is we look what's going on in Sweden
where we're now getting into the chip
territory I don't like that that
frightens me because all your
information is on your person and it's
dangerous you know that's where you you
can get people that are you know they're
wealthy they're being also word scary
territory I go to Sweden I got a
daughter who lives there and it is a
magazine to see if I could live cash
list for a week oh and easy I had to go
to a rugby match at whicker's yeah then
I had to go to Paris and when i got to
paris i didn't have any money on me at
all i had my credit card which was as it
were contactless but it didn't work in
paris oh my god and i ended up in the
trailer e with my daughter who was
starving and i could I had to beg for a
few francs to give my daughter a burger
did they give somebody I think what
you're talking about is our older
generations will they be left behind by
the move to cash listeners conurbations
people still pay cash you don't have
access to bank well he still used to go
to the bank of cash you have to go so
far to get to the bank because what's
happening is they're closing the
branches in the cash machines which for
20 30 percent of the population I
suspect is going to be quite a point on
edge so there's a stat from Age UK and
what they say is cash is a great way to
limit your risk all the people often
rely on others to help with shopping and
accept that there is a risk of being
shortchanged if they only give a carer
or a neighbor 20 pound note then they
limit their risk substantially and it's
easy to see the change so that if there
is a problem you can raise it on the
spot whereas if you're waiting for your
credit card there's an organization
called the cash rebellion which is and
the guy who runs it says when you have a
fully digital system you have no weapon
to defend yourself if someone turns it
off Putin invades Sweden's largest
island Gotland it will be enough for him
to turn off the payment system now have
the country would even think about
taking these sorts of risks they would
demand some sort of analogue system but
I think it's in some ways scandalous
that our children go through school poor
kids don't even know what a mortgage is
and then their pledge and I do think if
you and of course we were knowing a bit
but if you have a pile of cash and you
see that cash go as you buy yourself
young people just live off a piece of
plastic always use
which tells them exactly how much money
they've spent on what and so they can
actually monitor the physical money in
your hands I think you value it people
miss out on a cashless society it's not
necessarily the old it's the people at
the Corleone bank what they'll say is
every million people in this country
that don't have bank accounts 1.3 yeah
so those people will struggle in terms
of going cashless because they don't
have cars they don't have access to
those things and if you're looking
places like Philadelphia what they have
now done is they have made it illegal to
have cashless stores so you have to you
have to be able to offer people the
ability and facility to pay with cash if
that's what they want to do which I
found interesting but one of the final
nails in the coffin for money maybe is
the fact that monopoly is going to
launch a cashless you can only use
cashless or a biast - if anyone knows
what a Vyasa pants are I did I mean it's
going to become another form of cash as
all things becoming once everything is
on well we were all going to use your
bitcoins it continued lost most of your
money watch if you've not been month by
the way anyway this week marked the end
of Theresa Meers Premiership and Wow has
it been a bumpy ride but before the
prime minister gets the leopard-print
boots so it's just time to reflect on
everything she's accomplished during her
time in number 10 from that's p45
moments to her unbelievable teca's work
matching every outfit with different
types of a well-known shampoo brand like
hair or lower resume
[Applause]
and while she hasn't managed to deliver
brexit as strong and stable leader can
look back on her time as PM with pride
and a certainty that she truly is the
Home Counties dancing queen before we
say our final farewell there's just time
to look at her parting gift to one lucky
crowd at Henley festival in Oxfordshire
[Music]
[Applause]
Teresa for all that as well as giving us
great value for money out of this and
more thank you
you are our bricks it means brexit we
will never look a field of wheat the
same way again I suspect in a few weeks
time we'll be looking back fondly on it
wasn't difficult enough Waterloo that
it's for this week on the pledge but
don't forget you can join in the debate
by searching for us on Facebook or
Twitter and you can now listen for the
program on the go with Apple podcast
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]